dernière page de notre journal can le
palmarès c'est pour vendredi et déjà
bien sûr on commence à avancer quelques
noms notamment pour les prix
d'interprétation chez les hommes le plus
prononcé celui d'Alberto Sordi Alberto
Sordi veut d'être ultra connu chez nos
amis italiens qui je sais sont très
nombreux les coups d'Antenne 2 ultra
connu là-bas mais pratiquement pas en
France pourtant il a derrière lui une
collection impressionnante de film
c'était tous d'ailleurs des rôles
comique et c'est son premier emploi
dramatique quiil a fait remarquer à Cann
un film de Mario monich
un bourgeois petit
petit mais depuis 25 ans c'est la
première fois que je suis plus un acteur
comique mais je fais des drames aussi
des tragédies j'ai jou alors ça c une
surprise pour t les public italien et
j'espère pour t le public du monde quand
j'avais 6 ans je chanta avec la voix
blanche dans la chapelle Sistine de le
Vatican et après à 11 ans j'ai j'ai subi
un métamorphhe je suis devenu un bass et
tout le monde crie à les miracles parce
que je suis un bass à 11 ans que
faisaient vos parents pour vous mettre
chanteur dans les cœurs du Vatican mais
mes parents on ne dit rien parce que je
suis un bourgeois petit petit je suis né
dans une famille de de bourgeois ma mère
c'est maître l'école mon preit un
professeur
d'orchestre un hom très gentil mais très
modeste il connait son
limiteasi a te Mario te ne capiteranno
quando io c'avevo l'età tua sta attenta
che Bagnato si scivola vedi Mario che
tipo di ragazza è lì quelle dall'aria un
po' per bene quelle sospetteogna St
molto attenti perché sono sonoio quelle
che ti
incastrano le ragazze bisogna conoscerle
conoscerle profondamente perché sen che
fai le metti a casa
estrane prendi quella ragazza lì per
esempio è Carina a te ti piace lo so ma
chi è chi la conosce ecco
[Applaudissements]
perché ma che è
successoo porca Troia
sbrigatgato
Mario
[Musique]
non
Mario son papa son papa et quand je
proposé de de voulerir faire
l'ter je j'ai des possibilités de
d'avoir des soucess lui me regarder
comme ça avec ceci est dou
dit c'est un rêve d'enfant ne pense pas
que tu peux arriver à le sess parce que
c'est très difficile dans la vie tout le
monde il veut arriver à les sess alors
pense que c'est c'est très difficile si
tu veux faire faire mais c'est très
difficile et vous avez pensé à lui en
jouant le Piccolo Piccolo bourgaise et
malheureusement mon père n n'a pas vu su
16 mais c'est il est dans quelque part
on voit que que c'est comme ça